the school really wants to get in the
way of the relationship between parents
and their children and you have guidance
counselors now I'm sure you know that
are being told by Administration keep it
confidential don't make phone calls home
to parents you need to make sure these
kids are protected and they present it
as a guide of protection essentially
against their own parents so you have
kids being turned against their parents
in many respects and they feel like the
parents are the enemy they no longer
speak to their parents it breaks down
the lines of communication which
essentially enables you know
indoctrination on many levels then then
you have students in oftentimes
left-wing institutions they're not
communicating with their parents and
larger issues begin to you know be
received in terms of the indoctrination
that we see in schools
foreign
[Music]